avec ce second confinement que certains
trouvent trop laxistes les esprits
commencent à s'échauffer
si certains réclament le port du masque
à la maison d'autres veulent carrément
interdire toutes les sorties vous le
sortir et je la laisse étrangers mais
aujourd'hui c'est un épidémiologiste
dont la cible est toute trouvée les
fêtards pour martin blachier le jour où
la france devrait rentrer dans un dé
confinement il est essentiel d'encadrer
les fêtes pour que les jeunes ne
reprennent pas leurs rassemblements
comme avant mais alors que propose-t-il
que l'on fasse aux fêtards martin
blanchi pense que pour dissuader les
jeunes de faire la fête
la sanction financière reste la plus
efficace et qu'on se le dise il n'y va
pas avec le dos de la cuillère il va
falloir être beaucoup plus dur
d'ailleurs que des jeunes qui font des
fêtes alors que c'est pas autorisé
c'est pas 150 euros damende il faut leur
mettre dix mille euros damende une
sanction financière qui va demander pas
mal d'argent pour organiser les
prochaines soirées
tu vas demander de l'argent de poche
attaques en mer pour aller au resto
alors êtes vous d'accord avec une
proposition de dix mille euros d'amendé
pour les pétards moi je pense la
question elle est vite répandue s'est
raidi notamment pour les pétales que
vous n'êtes pas au resto ou jack quand
j'attends votre réponse chez vous
l'égérie et bien sûr il ya la grande
race track y arrive c'est une grande
race sera inédite un c'est que d'effets
notables à chier et avec yoplait martin
la chute avec doute j'aimerais que ce
soit mais vous il est avec nous vous
êtes épidémiologistes on sait déjà que
faisait déjà reçu dans balances ton pote
et vous pensez que le plus grave en ce
moment c'est les fêtards qui ne
respectent pas le confinement vous dites
10000euros d'avant pour les bêta et au
moins ça va tout bloquer je vois des
gens qui peut être applaudie dans public
un regard des matières go là bas y en a
qui disent c'est n'importe quoi y'a qu'à
pays c'est y qui sont d'accord avec vous
il a beaucoup pourquoi je parlais
surtout qu'on reste des confiseurs se
met d'accord je passe sur qui énormément
de fait pendant confinement y en a
encore un season encore c'est gravissime
le problème c'est l'effet du confinement
l'effet du confinement c'est un drame
pour tout le pays c'est un drame pour
tous les petits commerces ans un drame
pour l'hôpital et on sait maintenant que
ce qu'elle relance et ça c'est
effectivement des fêtes dans le cercle
privé parce que les bars les boîtes tout
était fermé et peut-être qu'on en est là
à cause de ça donc je trouve que 150
euros damende c'est ce que les gens
dépensent dans une soirée bien sûr c'est
ridicule et c'est dix souhaitent
personnes je pense que dire
soyez gentil penser aux autres ou alors
dire les jeunes peuvent être très
gravement atteint est montré des jeunes
en reste ça marche pas je pense qu'il
faut une sanction qui soient lourdes
dissuasive on sait pas faire de la
dissuasion en france je pense que les
photos dissuasives comme les anglo
saxons et 10
l'euro ça me paraît une somme qui est
ridicule par rapport au coût de ce qu'on
vit en ce moment avec ce confinement
d'accord ça vous avez vu ça gilles
verdez est d'accord moi je suis d'accord
en angleterre il ya eu 45000 euros
d'amendé pour 4 fêtards donc ces onze
mille chacun en australie 16 mille euros
d'amendé pour un anniversaire ou le
monde tu avais des camps et nous nous ne
fait rien j'en ai marre qu'on soit mou
il faut sanctionner les poches et la
sanction que les gens écoutent c'est
effectivement le portefeuille
donc faut taper fort et cher au
portefeuille de kelly est d'accord aussi
bas moi je suis d'accord parce qu'il ya
un moment donné où quand on respecte pas
et qu'on fait un peu sa life et ben un
moment donné les jeunes il faut un
crédit dès le début de leur vie pour
payer une amende au détriment ou pour
avoir risqué la vie des gens voilà moi
je suis ici j'essaie d'aller y en a
marre quand on est assez d'accord avec
kelly également jean michel maire n'en
ont pas c'est normal ou normal on voit
les deux fêtards ils sont pas d'accord
vraiment il est vrai je dis non c'est
jimmy la soul à pourquoi pas 50 milles
c'est dissuasif mais ça changera quoi
ils vont être vénère ils vont avoir fait
la fête qui seront le vénère ils vont
cueillir dit maintenant qu'on a payé on
va encore plus faire la fête c'est pas
d'aidé pour les alertes et les amis sont
les a vues qu'on les oblige à ce moment
là et dans les hôpitaux voir la
situation et faire des travaux d'intérêt
général dans l'association est vrai que
c'est fait
c'est ce dont on parlait tout à l'heure
c'est l'intérêt qu'a un monsieur comme
atalay parler aux jeunes moi je suis pas
du tout aimé comme disait martin
blachier d'hawaï l attaque est venue ici
aussi qu'ils étaient excellents qui est
très sympa voilà mais quand vous dites
oui attention vous aussi vous pouvez
toucher là si vous taper du poing sur la
table et vous dites ces 10000 euros
moi je dis pas que tu pour mais en tout
cas ça peut être dissuasif je crois
quand on sait que ce que vient nous dire
martin qui épidémiologistes extrêmement
sérieux nous dit que la deuxième vague
elle vient surtout à cause de ces fêtes
qui ont été faits quand on parle de
troisième vague actuellement la
troisième vague elle va arriver marque
un pas si on fait n'importe quoi elle
risque la rue est donc là ça c'est pour
éviter une troisième vague c'est cette
histoire mais de là à mettre la faute
sur les mômes de 20 ans qui non mais on
leur met pas la main dessus ont laissé
un peu moi je les comprends tout à fait
je vous dis la vérité
oui répond non pas sur ma fiche êtes
vous d'accord avec la proposition
d'amandes de 10000 euros non je suis pas
d'accord avec la proposition faut
maintenant alors là non mais non mais je
suis pas d'accord entre la et laffineur
êtes vous d'accord c'est pas bon c'est
donc ils sont andy murray fait je vous
aimais beaucoup parce que je vous voyais
sur les plateaux de télé mais là de
sortir des conneries comme ça dix mille
euros damende si comme a dit jean-michel
vingt mille trente mille cinquante mille
comprends votre appartement
vous dites les soirées des 250 euros ou
kim et 150 au pour à la une soirée moi
les gens je connais on met pas 150 euros
pour aller le soir et on peut la une sur
blanc met en 30 euros 40 euros 50 ans et
des jeunes voulaient plombé direct dans
la vie avec 10000 euros damende il ya
des mecs qui sont les plus grosses
pertes est incapable de faire tomber
attendait donc pas faire de vagues
d'accord mais là on est constituée sur
wii est compilé à cause de ses gonds
pensé moi tu à cause des fêtes qu'est ce
que vous en savez pas ce qu'est la
réponse est comme le bon il est plus
développée on y voit les clusters on
nous dit alors alors alors regarde
compte des conneries aussi les et les
écologistes là comme ça je savais ce que
cette dix mille euros que les gens
l'acier vous savez ce que c'est 100
milliards c'est ce que coûte ce
gonflement 100 milliards d'euros c'est
notre génération qui s'étendait sur 30
ans pour payer 100 milliards d'euros
parce qu'il ya quelques personnes et
responsables qu'on fait des fêtes alors
qu'on a cessé de leur dire ne pas le
faire donc dix mille euros c'est rien
jara pour être bien plus ces gens
franchi chine
j'ai fait des histoires et que c'est pas
respecté c'est pas d'ma manque que vous
créez
c'est fait c'est gravissime quand on
voit ce qui se passe dix mille euros
c'est très peu docteur espaces conseils
que vous faites une set je vous avais je
pense votre note social qui est dégradée
de vous pouvez plus rien faire si vous
pouvez sans doute plus acheter
d'appartements vous pouvez plus avoir de
travail non mais c'est de parler de la
chine les mecs vous êtes sérieux en
australie ou ne portait pas le mac dans
la rue c'est plus de 2000 euros d'amendé
et ça marche non mais laissez les gens
là des gens qui en ce moment pour
appuyer votre demande sur un plan pénal
qui réfléchissent au fait que s'il y
avait des contaminations lors d'une fête
par exemple vous faites une fête vous
contaminer quelqu'un après cette
personne est positive imaginons qu'il ya
un décès il pourrait y avoir des mises
en examen pour homicide involontaire
non seulement il y aurait l'argent mais
possiblement possiblement des sanctions
pénales
il ya des gens qui sont pour ça donc je
suis pas du tout d'accord avec raymond
il faut sanctionner très durement
isabelle est d'accord aussi oui mais moi
je suis d'accord avec vous évidemment
que la somme semble énorme l ai dit elle
est supposée dissuasive et ne pas
pouvoir faire et effectivement quand on
voit le coût de cette crise ce
compliment qui se chiffrent par
centaines de milliards de dollars
d'euros s'est déjà vérifié
alors rené il n'est pas d'accord avec
cette proposition de dix mille euros
d'amendé pour les fêtards maintenant que
commercy connexion commettre des
sanctions je suis d'accord moi je suis
le premier je sors jamie je saurai plus
à papa lé la radio est ici donc je
comprends pas que les autres ne fassent
pas le même effort
mais de là à des 10000 euros il faut des
stations est obligé de les fermer
pendant certains blachier il faut
l'écouter quand il dit pensez aussi vous
n'aurez pas ici des restaurateurs et
commerçants qui eux vont devoir fermer
leurs magasins
c'est que de 2,2 de fait je suis
vraiment comment ils seront payés les
10000 euros si vous êtes des marins
comme données par mois mais attendez moi
je me fais serre et 10000 euros
par chance je vais emprunter je vais
faire je les ai alors là on les a c'est
aussi juste ne m'appelez pas et j'ai
tapé dans la mer je vais l'appeler quand
même maintenant nous attraper des jeunes
ils sont serrés il n'est 10000 euros
vous allez récupérer comment des fois tu
demandes 1000 euros damende 500 euros
d'amendé les gens ils n'auraient pas 500
euros sur leur compte
qu'est ce que c'est que cette utopie de
demander dix mille balles aux gens vous
croyez que les gens ils peuvent vous
aider les âmes en 2000 euros et
n'existent pas pour d'autres causes
comme réal et un appartement vous allez
avoir bétail télé millions d'années un
appartement basse est aujourd'hui de
faire une fête et roja mais moi
confinement a été relâché je comprends
tout à fait ce que vous dites là là là
en tout cas je pense c'est moins grave
quand même d'aller cambrioler de faire
une fleur de cambrioler un appartement
mais parce qu'on se rend pas compte
parce qu'on se bat qu'on ne voit pas les
faits mais quelques fait c'est des
événements super contaminateur ensuite
tout le monde va contaminer son sel et
c'est comme ça qu'on relance une
épidémie donc si on avait contrôlé se
fait donc sur ça je suis dit qu'on avait
été plus dure à son nom mais là c'est
son milhas on était plein de commerces
qui vont être fermés c'est bien plus
grave que quelque chose qui s'envoleront
à vous dit en fait marquant l'article
amende de 150 euros
c'est ridicule alors c'est ce que vous
êtes on va dire que les fêtes continue
et qu'il est bon coup et on continue et
c'est ça qui dit que science des confits
néo cons à 150 euros d'amendé
un rappel à la loi c'est sûr que ça va
pas dissuader les gens de les faire et
d'ailleurs c'est pas du cmem pas un bon
message qu'on envoie aux gens parce
qu'il faut envoyer un message de gravité
et la gravité c'est la somme qu'on
présente le monde anglo saxon l'a très
bien compris
en france je sais pas pourquoi on
continue est terminée en carnage annoncé
passé merci benjamin
mais si ça marchait justin juste pour
vous rejoindre reçoit en ce moment c'est
la grande mode des textos avec soirées
clandestines ce soir à tel endroit qui
sera donc c'est bien la preuve
qu'aujourd'hui il avait atteint le
plancher rooney non mais c'est bien la
preuve aujourd'hui que les gens faut
absolument qu'il y avait là quelque
sorte de gens la plupart des gens 95%
des gens il ya directement la nana 5% de
genre était la marraine et pour finir
voici ses héros du sein mais qu'est ce
que vous vous dites ça c'est dit c'est
une bonne réponse que vous avez cédé
jeudi 10 à 5% de gens comme vous dites
qu'ils font des soirées clandestines
les gens qui me contactent benjamin
redit ce que vous avez dit c'est les
bobos bourgeois ils pourront payer
voilà bah je dis mais ça ne vous opposez
pas si quelqu'un d'autre fait une
connerie et on fait les 10000 euros vous
les aurez ce que je crois non mon humble
contribution ce que je crois c'est que
vous êtes bien réducteur qui est à côté
de moi il est dans une atmosphère et
dynamique on connaît pas et nous est
épouvantable bien sûr absire que lui son
boulot c'est tout les jours d'aller
essayer de sauver des gens bien sûr
j'entends ce que ça veut dire dix mille
euros mais puisque je vais vous dire
docteur c'est pas je comprends tout à
fait ce que vous vivez et je serai pas
loin de vous rejoindre mais je pense que
en fait la punition n'a jamais empêché
le mauvais actes la preuve au moment de
la moment de la prohibition l'alcool
circulaient et c'est ce qu'il faut
expliquer et vous êtes là et vous le
faites très bien docteur j'ai vu à
plusieurs reprises à la télé c'est
expliquer à quel point c'est grave et
dangereux mais je peux comprendre ne
marche pas vous soyez et casey mais je
passais ça fait six mois qu'on le fait
on va on a le ministre de la santé qui
va dans les chambres des regards des
saints passion de 27 ans est ravie si ça
ne marchera pas vous pensez vraiment que
c'est ça qui fait que dans un mois quand
vous allez dès confiné à genève
elle va pas organiser si vous permettez
jusqu'à il ya encore quelques mois il y
en a aucun de vous qu'ils étaient
d'accord sur les plateaux de télé non
mes fans
oui mais je prends rien de personnel
hors jeu mais ce que je vais vous dire
c'est qu'on écoutait des
épidémiologistes raul machin dire une
fois la chloroquine une fois ça ira
l'association il y aura pas machin et on
a entendu tout et n'importe quoi
maintenant
maintenant là depuis quelques semaines
vous êtes tous d'accord et j'ai
l'impression que la population vous suit
et il faut continuer à ce qu'elle vous
suivent mais jusqu alors vous pouvez pas
en vouloir aux mômes extra de rien
comprendre
à un moment on a dit le masque
obligatoire après le masque obligatoire
après les jeux ne sont pas touchés alors
après c'est vous vous l'entendez ça me
le fait qu'il fallait pas faire des
soirées clandestines tout le monde est
d'accord ils peuvent le comprendre donc
soit il respecte mablas doivent le
comprendre
joël areva perd on peut le comprendre
avant c'était pas clair c'est ce qui me
semble tout à le comprendre ou s'il faut
pas rouler à 200 sur lottotech enroulé à
200 on n'a pas dix mille euros damende
même si ceux qui peuvent les payer c'est
la différence entre un risque individuel
que vous parle collectif la boue qu'on
avait ce collectif pour la station sera
en effet c'est surtout parce que tu veux
des gens chez nous tous et la société
française dans une situation dramatique
en train de s'endetter pour 30 ans c'est
plein de choses qu'on pourra pas faire
demain des nouveaux projets des
nouvelles voies ferroviaires des
nouvelles routes pourra pas faire parce
qu on s'endette juste pour quelques fait
qu'on n'a pas su tunis à melbourne et du
gouvernement n'avait eu des pics à taux
beaucoup plus clair beaucoup plus n'est
pas qu'une tournée sur terre ne ment du
même métal et ses discours il est
toutefois qu'il a dit je sais pas quoi
loties le le verra il a dit officieux
que la rencontre
montant de l'amendé je suis mais
fondamentalement en désaccord avec
raymond raymond vous avez tort le une
amende n'est pas proportionnée aux
revenus que l'ont arrimé au salaire que
l'on reçoit une amende
quand vous si vous prenez 10000 euros
damende ça va être une saisie sur
salaire pendant cinq ans à 200 euros par
mois qui pendant cinq ans va vous faire
penser [ __ ] j'ai fait une énorme
connerie c'est pour ça que ces amendes
sont nécessaires parce qu'elles vont
dissuader pour les années justement et
c'est pas parce qu'on gagne très peu
qu'on peut pas être lourdement la migros
venu répondu les amende de 10000 euros
varrault stu et eu égard intelligent
rang 5 twh ça correspond à quelle béni
l'adil monsieur tard des cambriolages
des braquages des trafics de la hongrie
samedi ses dix mille euros c'est la
coq10 asie cela facile mais la base
c'est un train de m'expliquer pour une
fête son récit la régie ventre puisque
je vous ai bien dit que c'est c'est eh
oui tu le monde a fait les cons fed est
en train de tuer mais parce que tous
autour du plateau les 10000 euros pour
vous seriez m
c'est un support peuvent à chaque fois
d'une édition verra regarde moi dans les
yeux tu crois que les gamins de 20 ans
ils vont te sortir diminuer ses six qui
visent les gens ils ont pas diminué donc
au chômage sans galère il ya une
mauvaise ambiance informations aux
galères et tous les mois tu vas donner
150 objets saisis sur salon chance de
faire les spectateurs elle a beaucoup
beaucoup d'outils dont on garde oui à
54% non à 46%
et vous savez que puisque tp aurait
plutôt un ce joli voilà et c'est bon
signe
eh ben c'est beau c'est toi c'est le cas
d'accord avec vous martin blachier ou
progresser avec nous martin
m